ce sont des diamants créé en laboratoire
de différentes couleurs des recettes
d'alix gicquel ce jour-là elle présente
ses différentes créations à cécile da
rocha dirigeante d'une start-up
implantée à montigny le bretonneux
jeannard hausse est une marque de
joaillerie responsables ont créé des
bijoux uniques intemporel éthique et
durable
on s'est intéressés du coup au diamant
créer un laboratoire pour se fournir
cécile da rocha se tourner vers cette
société de production de diamants de
synthèse en laboratoire créé en 2016
elle vient de s'installer dans
l'accélérateur d'air liquide aux loges
en josas c'est le démarrage de la
préindustrialisation objectifs pour
l'année prochaine produit un mille 500
carats de diamants de synthèse grâce à
ses six réacteurs en installation on
part d'un petit germes de diamants qui
est mono cristallin pour le met dans un
réacteur à placement on va introduire
des gaz du de l'hydrogène moléculaire et
on va produire du méthane on va envoyer
des micro ondes et les micros devons
créer une décharge électrique dans ce
gaz et on va donc avoir une production
d'atomes de carbone dans le dans le
milieu gazeux ces atomes de carbone vont
permettre la formation du diamant à
partir du germe
ils ressortent sous cette forme là le
premier c'est un diamant brut qui sort
du réacteur comme ça au milieu il ya le
mono cristal et autour il y à ce qu'on
appelle le poly cristallin qui est noir
on prend le laser de des coûts et aux
corps ont des tours pour sortir le mono
cristal ensuite on l'envoie chez un
tailleur et le tailleur fait des
merveilles comme le petit diamant qui à
côté le coussin briand qui est champagne
sur le long terme pour cette société
l'objectif est de produire huit mille
carats sur différentes plateformes de
production